Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast and um,
jazz check in,
in.
Aw.
Specifically the ladies.
I'm checking in on the ladies to make sure that you feel okay,
that you feel like you're in a safe space to listen to this podcast.
Not because I care,
because I want to start trending on Twitter.
MMM.
Jesus Christ.
Jesus Christ with the award shows in the fucking the same speech given every
award show always called brave as if somebody's going to heckle it,
you know,
like something.
Yeah.
Nobody's going to say that.
We're all gonna sit there and be like,
wow.
That thing that was already said was just said again,
but this time it was said even better.
Hey,
keeps saying the thing you already said.
I want to go out there and say the thing that was already fed.
I want to be that person.
I wouldn't be brave.
You want to be brave.
You go the other way.
And I said,
I know there's a lot of guys out there took the dicks out at work,
but what about these gold digging whores?
Am I right fellas that now that would be brave.
Be Brave.
Okay,
good.
I think to see you fucking walk out of that one.
I'm saying the thing that's been said that everybody gets,
once again,
we'll be right back with the saying the thing that's always said it everything
now award show after these messages.
You know,
people,
while we were away,
something else was said that was already said that needed to be said again in
case anybody didn't hear it the first 19,000 times it was said,
um,
you know,
and like I swear to God and this is all it does,
is it just causes of copycat fucking behavior.
Same thing with these mass shootings,
you know,
which is why they shouldn't report on him because then everybody wants to do it.
Right?
Fucking some chick makes a porn and becomes fucking super famous.
Now every broad out there starts fucking dropping their panties.
I looked it up.
It happens.
Right?
So now fucking Pete is getting into it.
They're trying to say,
you can't say beat a dead horse.
And then they came up with all this dumb shit.
There's no fucking way that this,
this can't be coming from Peter.
Like they said,
when it's raining out,
don't say it's raining cats and dogs that promotes violence towards,
it's just,
you know,
can you say it's a frog strangler?
MMM.
You can't listen to Christmas music.
You know what I mean?
Are they going to go through all of the catalog now?
That song I really cared.
Stay cause baby,
it's cold outside.
I really can't stay was saying that that promoted some sorta rape or then don't
it under the apple tree.
What?
Anyone else?
What me that's controlling.
She can sit under whatever apple tree she wants to.
I think the meeting was that was,
hey,
don't go and fucking suck some other Dick while I'm off fighting war.
You know,
fight the war here.
Defending the country,
you know?
But you know,
you couldn't say that back then,
right baby?
It's cold out or does it go well I really can't stay baby.
It's cold outside.
I got to go away,
baby.
It's cold outside.
This evening has been been opened that you drop in.
So great.
This is such a cute fucking saga.
There's a bunch of fucking songs out there that you could just turn into some
shit.
Right.
Um,
anyways,
needless to say,
that's my new walk on music when I do a standup.
Sure.
You know what's funny?
I don't even like that song.
It's,
it's a fucking Corny Goddamn song.
I don't even fucking like it,
but I'm such a cunt,
you know?
Actually to be honest with you,
I think there needs to be some sort of a turning down the spigot on this fucking
insanity because it's literally 8% of the population is acting like they're
speaking for or evidently babysitting the fucking rest of us.
But like I think I could listen to that song and not rape anybody.
I've done it for 50 years.
I'm going to go out on a limb and think I'm going to be okay.
You know,
this goes like back to when they thought listening to Judas priest and all of
that Shit,
you know,
made you go out and fucking kill yourself and do all that,
which we all know is,
is it really comes down to just bad parenting.
Um,
it is a thing I know most women don't give a fuck about,
you know,
if you put on that song,
you know what I mean?
I know.
Okay.
I Dunno.
Was it brave to do what I just did?
That's what you do.
You're going in an award show,
you do a fucking tap dance.
Yeah.
Two,
I really can't stay.
And then you come out and you talk about gold digging horse.
MMM.
You know,
and then you try to like,
you,
you go for the,
the anti that crowd.
I bet that could still fill in arena.
Right?
I'm sorry,
I don't,
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about here.
Um,
fucking Peta.
I love animals too.
Do you,
do you know how much of a dose you have to be for somebody,
be behind your cause and also to be sitting there going,
the ace people are fucking assholes.
MMM.
I think I just describe myself as a person because my wife loves me,
but she really seems to side with other people a lot of the times,
you know?
Um,
anyway,
so let's,
let's,
let's plow ahead here into the podcast,
into the podcast.
I want to thank everybody on the Seth Meyers show for having me on.
I had a great time promoting,
uh,
so he's a three of f is for family as far as I can tell from the tweets.
It seems to be going really well.
People seems to be really enjoying,
but why wouldn't they?
We already have a great cast.
We already have a bunch of murderers in the writers' room and we added Vince
Vaughn.
That's right.
Spoiler alert.
Listen closely Vince font.
You'll hear his voice or the character that he's doing on season three.
And I'm really excited that people are enjoying it.
And I just want to say right now to all the brave people out there that are
fighting out there to try and get Netflix.
I just want to you to know that your voice is heard.
It's heard by me,
and that there's a bunch of people out there that love you when you try to sign
on and just,
you know,
try to stay positive.
Um,
I flew back from New York,
uh,
yesterday and,
um,
I was one of those,
one of the rare times of the year where you land over the water on at lax.
So usually,
you know,
usually the winds coming in off the water,
so you take off and land into the wind.
But this is the time we actually,
we came around,
landed,
it was pretty fucking cool.
Um,
except was too cloudy for me to see the approach.
You know,
I'm a fucking nerd when it comes to that stuff.
But anyways,
when I was on the plane,
I actually watched a premiere league soccer game.
I watched,
I watched a arsenal versus man United and I gotta Tell Ya,
I really fucking enjoyed the game.
You know,
and I'm starting to understand it.
I saw now I understand why
one thing was off site.
Do you know when they all line up and they cover their junk and somebody tries
to fucking bend it like Beckham around them?
You don't like that's stupid ass movie.
I never fucking saw they were saying that this,
they scored a goal on that.
Maybe they were off site.
It's basically any party,
a body that could score a goal
if it's behind that line on the offensive.
If you're an offensive player.
So this guy went to go make a move and as you know you lead with your head when
you start to run,
unless,
I dunno,
you're doing that dance underneath the stick there.
Right.
Um,
so I guess he was off site.
So I guess I understand that
it really takes away a lot of the excitement he should be able to take off a
little bit.
Well I get it cause they have to stand there and try to block it.
And then if the offensive players,
you know,
they don't give a shit,
they want that it's going to take off.
Okay,
I get it.
Um,
I gotta tell you some bad,
bad,
bad fucking defense and that God damn game be time,
Arsenal score.
Then they turn around,
they just fucking gave up another one,
that long fucking pass.
I don't know any of the terminology,
but I just know that that that shouldn't happen.
Sorry lolly gag and going after the ball and that little cunt came running up
and kicked it in with his fucking toe hair.
That shouldn't happen.
Um,
but it was a,
it was a great game and um,
okay.
I Dunno,
I haven't been drinking.
It just made me want to booze.
There's something about watching the premier league game at night.
It's always fucking raining.
It's always like misty.
It just looks like,
yeah,
I want to fucking start the fire and drink like,
you know,
seven or eight pints.
Why wouldn't yet the cell about saying a pint?
You feel like you're a fucking world traveler and you don't feel like you're a
fucking alcoholic.
Speaking of which,
I actually watched this thing on youtube called what kind of drink or am I that
I'll be discussing with Joe to Rosa on uninformed.
The next episode I might Patrion page and um,
I went and I looked up those alkie questions.
Okay.
Because this guy sounded like me.
Like,
you know,
I can stop when I want to.
I don't wake up shaking and have to drink fucking booze.
I'm not an alcoholic.
What kind of drink or am I okay.
Are,
and I answered the questions dude.
All right.
Are you an El Co Hall?
Lik All right,
here we go.
Here we go.
Drug addiction treatment.
Are you high functioning?
Uh,
wait,
I got to see.
Oh,
quiz,
alcohol problems.
Screening,
quiz.
Oh boy.
If I,
okay,
question one.
Okay.
Do you sometimes drink more than you planned to drink?
Oh,
I don't have a plan other than I'm going out.
Let's see if I drink it all.
I have only one or two before dinner.
Okay.
I hope any joke I tell tonight we'll be funnier than that line.
No,
that's not me.
I will occasionally skip or delay meals to have a couple more drinks.
Uh,
well I've drank for a period where I didn't realize when I drink until I'm
hungry,
you know,
and then I get a slice at the end of the night.
Wait,
sometimes a few with the boys slash girls turns into an entire evening.
Well,
I never just go out for a few.
I go out with the specific.
Okay.
MMM.
I go out to get hammered.
I've been on benders that lasted for days.
No,
I haven't done that.
I mean,
I my,
unless you call consecutive nights of drinking,
but I mean,
I sober up and go,
what am I doing?
And then the next night I have another one.
All right.
Do you sometimes drink more than you planned to drink?
If it'll occasional skip sometimes.
I guess the closest one was would be the third one,
c sometimes a few with the boys slash girls turns into an entirely new thing.
Yeah,
that's fair.
All right,
let's check that.
Okay.
Yeah.
At the end of this quiz,
someone's trying to make money off of me so you know,
I'm going to flunk it and I need their help.
All right.
Have you ever tried to quit drinking and were unsuccessful?
I don't want to quit.
I enjoy an occasional drink.
I thought about quitting,
but I've just gotten around,
but I haven't got around to it.
I've tried to control my drinking,
but it hasn't worked for very long.
I've tried to quit drinking many times.
Uh,
I go on sabbaticals.
I like,
I need to shut it down.
Okay.
And I've been able to do that,
but then I just get bored.
I just keep pouring and I,
you know,
like,
what am I never going to have another drink?
Okay.
So I guess I've tried to,
my drinking and it hasn't worked for very long.
Well,
I've gone a year.
All right.
How much time do you spend each week drinking?
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
I don't know.
I only drink on special occasions or no,
no,
no.
I only drink on weekend and I drank at least three nights a week.
Now we're getting there.
I drank almost daily.
As soon as I get off work.
Ding,
Ding.
All right.
Do you have an,
do you ever get an urge to drink or a craving for alcohol?
Yes.
Okay.
No,
I can take it or leave it.
Jesus Christ.
Somebody who works at a library.
All right.
Sometimes if I've gone a few days without a drink,
I'll get a desire to drink.
Yes.
If I skip a day drinking,
I'll have an urge to drink the next day.
No,
I can't wait until happy hour every day.
I'd say to,
uh,
the second one.
Number five.
Oh,
Billy booze hound.
He's almost halfway there.
Right.
How many fucking questions are there?
11.
Do you have to get board taking multiple choice questions now?
Right.
Do you often miss work or school or obligations that,
no,
I don't ever remember.
Miss.
No.
I've never,
yeah.
No.
No,
never.
I'm a Prof.
I wait till after the work's done.
Uh,
has your drinking negatively affected your social
okay,
or family relationships?
No,
I rarely drink enough to become intoxicated.
Now sometimes I haven't embarrassed myself by drinking.
Yes.
I prefer to hang out with people would pick as much as I do.
To that.
I have lost friends relationship?
No,
it's somewhere between B and C in,
in
sometimes I haven't barest myself while drinking and I also prefer to hang out
with people who drink as much as I do.
Um,
so I guess I picked the worst of the two.
That's only fair.
Have you given up hobbies or activities you used to enjoy now?
Alcohol doesn't interfere with my life.
No it doesn't.
I think I'm high functioning.
Does your drinking ever put you in a dangerous situation?
When I drink it's only at home.
Uh,
that's not true.
I have had a couple of drinks at lunch.
No return to work.
I've drank,
I have drinking.
I've driven after drinking before,
but I was not really drunk,
bad back in the day before I got arrested when I was 21.
I regularly drive home from the bar.
No,
I don't drive home.
Okay.
So where do I go with that one?
Yeah.
I have driven after drinking before,
but I was not really drunk.
Well I've done that.
Yeah.
You wait till you're sober,
I'll click on that one.
Has drinking caused you any persistent health problems?
No.
All right.
There we go.
Does alcohol still give you the same feeling?
One drink helps me relax.
Yeah.
Three beers used to do it.
Now it takes a six pack.
I changed to liquor because wine wasn't giving me a buzz.
I changed the liquor cause for the out for the calories.
Thought it was,
you know,
I mean,
I know they all have calories,
but I figured I'm just got a little shot glass if it's supposed to.
12 ounces.
MMM.
Alcohol still give you the same feeling?
Well,
I guess the closest one here,
one,
one drink helps me relax.
Um,
but I have changed the liquor cause wine wouldn't give me a buck.
Well it would,
but I have to drink too many.
Then I get like fucking acid reflux with that shit.
All right.
When you go out,
um,
without alcohol,
do you get withdrawal symptoms?
Now I don't feel any negative.
All right,
so now what does that mean?
Could you have an aisle?
You got a moderate alcohol problems?
Well,
I could have fucking told you that.
Um,
anyways,
yeah,
no,
I've been a,
I've been a good boy.
I haven't drank since the end of fucking November.
I'm coming up on two weeks,
you know,
and I'm doing it during the holidays and everybody's like,
lay them around.
I doing that.
I got to get in shape for this fucking European run that I'm doing.
European run.
Bill,
you don't say I've seen it on your website,
boy.
Oh boy.
A lot of them sold out any chance.
The yet is second shows in some cities.
Why?
Yes,
they have.
Okay.
January 5th,
Munich second show,
uh,
January six often buck,
they added a second show.
Uh,
January 8th and Riga,
Riga model.
They added a second show,
Vienna,
they added a second show.
Liverpool,
my adopted fucking premier league team,
I think.
I Dunno,
I got to,
I got to pick a team,
but I think it's going to be them and I'm doing it cause I liked the Beatles.
A London.
They added a second show,
March 5th,
Copenhagen,
Denmark,
April 30th in Helsinki.
The edit a second show.
I love it.
Yeah.
All right.
All Daddy's going to be over there fucking working.
So,
uh,
yeah.
So I cut it off.
I,
I got some sort of fucking issue cause last night I was sitting by the fire with
my wife.
I had lit,
you know,
put the Christmas lights on the tree and all of that shit.
We're having a great time.
I love the holidays.
So she goes,
you want some eggnog with a little in there,
you know,
she says,
and I said,
Nah,
I'll just take the egg.
Nog but I,
you know,
a little bit of a,
what's that shit you put on top of it?
The brown stuff,
not make a little nutmeg on top and I'll be good.
Okay.
Just gives you can't have just a little bit.
I go no,
because then I want to have a bunch more and then that could turn into a,
you know,
me drinking every night for the next week or for the next year.
Just about,
you know,
I'm a habit guy and if I'm not drinking,
I,
I'm either on or fucking off.
I be honest with you,
I lost that to kind of just like,
you know,
occasionally have a beer.
I have to like be not doing it or fucking doing it.
Now I can not do it I guess.
Okay.
The free time man,
I got too much fucking free time.
Um,
if I had like an,
you know what,
I need this,
I think the biggest problem with my Busan is,
is I don't,
I,
there's no rules.
That's all I need because what likes cigars?
I have rules,
you know,
as far as how many I'm going to have a,
I just have to have rules with alcohol.
So maybe like I was thinking what if like,
uh,
two Saturdays a month,
you know,
that would be perfect cause then I'd still go out and get to drink cause I
fucking love booze,
but then I won't be like negatively affected myself.
Um,
you know,
my also won't be bored shitless and they also won't be a bloated fuck.
So maybe in,
I feel like in a,
when I do the European tour,
maybe the second to last night,
just so I'm not hung over for the flight or whatever.
No.
Cause I know me.
Then I'll be like,
oh my God,
this flight's fucking longest shit.
Why don't we just have fucking three doubles real quick and just pass out,
wake up over fucking Greenland and be like,
yeah,
fuck.
We only have,
we didn't man.
Um,
whatever.
I'll figure it out.
Um,
let's see here.
Maybe I'll go to an AA meeting.
Every time I go to a fucking AA meeting,
I'm like,
Jesus Christ,
he's fucking,
people are crazy.
I just sit in a bar and drink and I get hammered and then I fucking go home.
That's it.
You know,
there's no cops there.
No fucking family.
Fucking common down there.
It's like these fucking stories.
Um,
there's no blood
jail and shit.
All right,
butcher box.
Everybody.
Butcher box delivers healthy 100% grass fed and grass finished beef free range,
organic chicken and heritage,
bread,
pork.
The incredible quality of butcher box meets starts with the commitment to
raising animals humanely and free of antibiotics and hormones before they're
murdered.
Cook with the cook with the peace of mind knowing you're eating healthy,
high quality meat.
Each box comes with at least 18 to 11 pounds of meats,
which is enough for 24 individual size meals.
Unless you're a gluttonous fat fuck,
you know,
you probably burned through it faster than I do a bottle of booze.
You can choose from five different box types.
All beef,
beef and chicken beef mix box custom box let you choose your own cuts.
Incredibly convenient.
Think of butcher box as your neighborhood butcher delivered right to your door
on dry ice for free.
Anywhere in the 48 states.
Choose your delivery frequency with the customizable subscription for Free Bacon
and $20 off your first box.
Go to butcher box.com/burr and enter burr at checkout.
All right.
Oh look who's Bodo though to Mandy's beyond these was an ad fucking brave.
Doh,
Doh.
Mandy's beyond days.
Don't go to a fucking rave.
It dropped fucking Molly and stand.
Work next to a crape.
Next thing you know,
his balls are red.
D.
Make sure you look out for yourselves this holiday season,
especially if they play baby,
it's cold outside.
I'm talking about me on days.
All right,
me undies,
every,
everybody soft as a fucking deers ass,
a reindeer.
Zass have you finished your holiday shopping yet?
No worries.
You can get everything you need for your loved ones at me.
Undies me undies uses the coveted micro modal modal fabric,
which is three times softer than cotton.
If you never felt this fabric,
get ready to experience pure bliss and underwear form.
You could also get a style that is perfectly suited for you or that special
someone,
men and women can choose from.
Four different cuts,
all of which are available from classic colors too.
Adventurous Prince.
But baby,
my balls are cold outside,
but wide stop at beyond.
These me undies has cozy lounge pants in onesies in that same super soft fabric,
perfect for wearing.
My balls are fucking cold,
uh,
for wearing Christmas morning
offer me,
Andy says,
had a great offer for my listeners for any first time purchasers.
Uh,
you're with your,
when you purchase any me undies,
you get 50% off and free shipping order by 1216 for free shipping in time for
Christmas crunch for time.
You can't go wrong with the me undies gift card.
This is a no brainer.
Get 50% off a pair of the most comfortable undies you will ever put on to get
50% off your first pair of free shipping and 100% satisfaction guaranteed.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash [inaudible] that's [inaudible] dot com slash
burr.
And lastly,
but not leastly hell acts.
Everybody.
You ever wake up in the morning with regrets of what you'd done?
Yeah.
Uh,
replaying the terrible decisions you made the previous night over and over and
over.
Yeah.
The kicking,
the sweat and the yelling.
Yeah.
Or whatever else you do to piss everyone off in the room.
Well,
guess what,
Bud?
Just deciding to sleep on a shitty mattress is your choice.
Uh,
well,
where would you buy something that you would enjoy it while you're in luck?
Because he likes sleep.
The mattress,
um,
I'm yelling at you about for almost two years.
Will Change Your Life.
Just go to he sleep.com/bar take their two minutes sleep quiz and they'll match
you to the perfect mattress.
It's like Tinder for a,
for finding a mattress.
All the fun with none of the next morning regrets in.
And right now you can get up to $125 off your mattress order at helix,
sleep.com/bar.
They have 101 hundred night trial,
free shipping and won't send you creepy next day texts.
That's Healy,
sleep.com/burr for up to $125 off your first mattress order.
All right.
By the way,
that George Bush book,
I was telling you where it talked about him flying and all of that shit that was
called fly boys,
not flags of our father.
It's fucking hilarious.
I barely read.
I know it's not a surprise.
Um,
and I can't even remember the name of the God damn book.
Then I fucking red.
That was the one with the George Bush stories.
But you know,
I,
I didn't feel too bad that I picked the other book too,
cause they're both incredible books.
Um,
all right,
what else do we got here?
Uh,
see award show speeches.
Talked about that arsenal,
man news,
Seth Meyers,
Christmas tree.
No booze.
Oh,
oh,
I told you,
I'm thinking about switching to smoke in a pipe.
Both my grandparents smoked a pipe and they're dead now.
So I think it's a good napkin.
Um,
I should have been thinking about doing that.
I like it.
I like the whole fucking ritual.
It's just seems really cool.
Sit down,
packing the thing,
lighten it,
having to relight it,
pack it down with that little fucking thing,
cleaning it out,
the whole God damn thing.
Um,
somebody get,
when I was in a course,
one of my favorite cities of all time,
Milwaukee,
Wisconsin,
I was there and they gave me a pipe,
you know,
and I just,
I had lost the thing and I just recently founded it.
It,
let me,
let me see,
I got it right over here next to the wall of my things here.
This is all of my things are on your,
wait a minute.
Wait,
a flare.
It is,
let's see what I got in here.
Is it just the pipe?
But I have the little,
the little packer thing,
like,
I don't know the name of all this.
I also like,
you know what I like about cigar smoking and,
and also,
uh,
smoking a pipe is,
it's really fucking obnoxious,
like cigar smokers just because it's just all encompassing and nobody can get
away with,
get away from it.
All right,
so I've got a pipe.
I have some pipe cleaner and then do I have in here?
Do I have a little fucking,
oh,
I still got to buy the thing to pack it down.
Oh my God.
Dude,
are you serious?
I gotta.
I gotta try this fucking thing out,
you know?
Yeah.
Oh,
there's a little thing for that,
that I watched this whole thing.
First of all,
I noticed people who smoke pipes have crazy facial hair.
Like,
I don't know if I'm going to fit in.
Like when I show up,
think that is a newbie.
Look at him.
He doesn't look like he,
uh,
you know,
he's a conductor or something like that.
Now Jesus,
you know what I want for Christmas?
I,
I really have to fucking fix this fucking God damn headphones here.
Why do I do this to myself?
What is,
you know,
it's gotta be this adapter thing.
That's what it is.
I just have to buy a nice one.
Yeah,
I'm literally,
I'm handling this right now.
I'm going to,
not right now,
but the podcast is over in a couple of minutes and then we have some greatest
hits,
another half hour.
So please by all means.
Yeah.
Okay.
This is a safe space to listen to a podcast.
Um,
okay.
Anyways,
I,
I'm in,
I'm going to order one of those goddamn things.
Then I also got a bunch of nieces and nephews and they're all getting Boston
fucking sports shit.
All right,
I don't want to hear it.
Okay.
That's it.
I care about sports.
Therefore you're going to care too.
And speaking of which,
let's see when Liverpool's next game is
Liverpool.
Uh,
Liverpool,
come on,
cause you know what?
I have the whole fucking month off and by the I just be,
by that I just mean I'm not gonna fucking
okay.
Oh,
it always goes to fucking Wiki p yet Jesus fucking Christ these cons.
Okay.
When the fuck did Google become set?
Why do I care?
Why do you care?
Who gives a fuck?
The Premier Li Diego Premier Li daily go.
Come on now.
Come on.
Gimme a break here.
All right.
They beat fallen to nothing.
They beat advertent one nothing.
The next game is Saturday 4:30 AM
okay.
Jesus Christ.
Fuck.
Am I going to watch that?
They got man United coming up.
That's gotta be a big one.
Sunday the 16th
Oh shit.
All right,
well let's see what's,
what's the fucking,
that's it.
You play once every 10 days.
I can't be right.
That can't be right.
I am clicking on Liverpool three to one.
Okay.
Stat timeline.
See,
everything's different in another fucking cut timeline.
What the fuck does it do?
How do,
how do I get schedule?
All right.
Let me hit pause here.
Sorry.
Hold on.
All right.
Yeah.
Did these Games a nice and spread out.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
This is fucking easy to follow.
All right,
so what do we got?
They got one on Saturday,
then they got Saturday the eighth and they got Sunday the 16th
then they got the 21st and the 26th
okay.
Then the 29th oh by,
if I watch all of those games,
I'll be on board.
All right.
That'd be great.
Liverpool on,
on one of these tours coming up.
You know I'm also doing Manchester City,
so Jesus Christ,
I'll get a bunch of shift.
They don't give a fuck.
Right?
I'm a stupid Yag then I can we give a shit.
Just be happy.
I'm watching.
They won't give a shit.
The perfect scenario would be if I become a Liverpool fan and then they lose
demand city.
Right.
So then like Liverpool,
people will be happy that I'm rooting for their fucking team then man.
See,
you won't give a fuck because my team didn't win bill.
I don't think they're going to give a fuck either way.
Hey,
fair enough.
All right.
Um,
anyways,
I'm so psyched to be home.
I'm so fucking psyched to be home.
I have the best fucking life in the world.
Get married was the smartest thing I ever did.
Good.
Considering all the pitch and I do about it.
It's fucking great.
I'm going to go inside.
Go have a nice fucking,
uh,
get out of the garage here,
calling to get a nice fucking warm meal here.
Sit around the God damn Christmas tree,
right.
Have a good time.
And in the meantime,
we're going to be listening to this,
a little bit of fucking music here and then a half hour of greatest hits from a
Thursday afternoon just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast from earlier this year or years ago.
I have no idea,
by the way.
Uh,
thank you to everybody that bought tickets to Patrice O'Neil comedy benefit on
February 19th,
2019.
It's just about,
uh,
I think just about soul died,
a couple hundred left.
I have to keep promoting it,
of course.
Um,
and that is it.
All right.
Go fuck yourselves and I'll check in on,
you know,
Oh wait,
I'm sorry.
Today's Thursday,
right?
Have a great weekend.
You've cuts.
That's what I'm supposed to say.
And I'll talk to you on Monday.
Hello.
Hi.
Wait a second.
The podcast isn't over yet.
I was supposed to do an inch after the music.
There's going to be a little clip from one of the uninformed episode three,
I believe from the Patriot and page,
give you a little taste.
They're like a drug dealer will hopefully make you go to the fucking patriarchy
to listen to the rest of it.
So here it is.
Me and all Joda Rosa,
the teen idol sensation from the bay,
the [inaudible] Anthony Program.
Uh,
talking about,
uh,
I think we're talking about being up.
Me Being a dad on this one.
I'm not sure.
I don't remember.
All right.
Enjoy it.
No,
that's less.
The bureau.
Some Joe,
God bless the people that love those things.
You know,
I'm going to shine.
Those are the kinds of people that fucking decorate their house on the holidays.
Neil loves him.
He is a fucking best and he is going to fucking,
you know,
deck the halls.
She's going to deck the halls.
That's high right now.
John going to throw up my back,
pushing my fucking trash cans to the corner because there was fold with like
$300 with a fucking pumpkin since she bought it for fucking,
um,
Halloween and Thanksgiving and it looked great.
Joe.
I like Martha Stewart would have walked in.
She would have been nervous and like,
Oh shit,
this,
this chick is common.
Right?
Then at the end of the day,
they got a fucking,
you know,
they've got to go out to the curb.
I was sitting there like,
the,
I never get one.
I'm like,
I'm just going to have to throw it away.
It felt like there was a fucking dead body in there.
Dude.
It was like,
wait,
as much as a person,
I never get one because I'm going am I going to,
and then I also never put my up the already haven't think if you did stuff like
that,
maybe you could sleep a little better.
Dude,
listen,
I love nothing more than,
than putting the tree up and decorated for Christmas.
Here's why I don't do it.
Pause of Holly.
Follow La la.
Oh,
Paul's bell.
What?
Bells.
They're like shaped the Holly bells are shaped like fucking people.
They're are trying to get the quarters.
Are these army people later on?
What branch there in?
Dang it.
Dang.
You know those guys at the mall?
No,
that's no Holly.
Bill fucking green shit with the berries on it.
Holly,
how are you saying those ELLs?
Yeah,
they're cog bells of Holly.
Like the things that you hang up,
those little bunches of Holly.
Oh,
I always had it.
I just thought it was literally bell's first.
I thought it was balls.
Maybe it means bells go.
I gotta be honest.
I shoot it my way through them.
We've got to look up this fucking Joe.
Is it,
has there ever been a fucking show named more perfectly uninformed.
I took a wild swing,
but I have a feeling of working title was dumb fucks.
That's gotta be,
that's gotta be what it is though.
Bells of Holly like,
like,
uh,
like bales of Hay or,
or you know what the fuck does,
hey,
you have to do with Holly.
I'm saying it's like the term,
like how you call a thing,
a hay bale of Hay.
All right.
I think you just call it a bell of Harley.
You know a Bushel of fruit.
In other words,
you know everything.
So many shaped bushels out there for me.
If you really know what it means to bill you been shaving your Bushel for years.
I had to it.
Ah,
we're both wrong.
Deck the halls with Bose of Holly,
B o u g h s o bows
fall la La la La la La la.
Tis the season to be jolly
la La la La la La la La Don.
We now are gay pair
la La la La la La la La.
Good little run DMC that,
wait a second,
Don.
We are done.
We are gone.
Dude,
don't jog about John June.
John means put on our gay apparel meeting.
Joyous festive means something on a bill's closet.
Zig Zag,
zoom the H and you'll tide Carol.
I never got what that meant through.
This is like how much English language changes.
This is like what the F,
I don't know what they're talking about here.
Let's see here.
You don't,
somebody did like a metal versions of this dude.
It's sick.
Yeah,
the whole lip.
Aldo.
Alright.
Rudy.
What the fuck is a bow Bo definition?
Like a bow took like a boat.
It's not B.
O.
W.
It's a main branch of a tree.
A branch,
a limb.
And Ah,
dude,
that's where bow and Arrow comes from my bet.
Because you would take a tree branch feel w you sure?
Positive mom.
Now,
I mean,
I'm just saying it.
This is how I spell it.
I'm bowl and Arrow.
Yes.
Definition of above.
Jesus.
Joe.
We're just learning stuff,
right and left Bo definition a man,
a male,
white male from the south.
Hey Bo,
get over.
Sorry.
A not tied with two loops and two loose ends to specifically to tie shoe last
night.
And a weapon for shooting arrows typically made of a curved piece of wood who's
ends are joined together by eight tots string.
All right,
and that's bow.
Yup.
All right.
Comes Joey d right down.
Joey d lane.
That's of God.
All right.
Um,
that's uninformed.
Joe,
I liked that we sang a little holiday.
So let's,
let's walk.
Let's,
let's end this.
It's,
it's the holiday season.
I don't know that word.
[inaudible]
where's,
what is that?
Don't take out yet.
Cock at the Christmas party or you get me to
keep your Nag.
Nag in your pants.
Yeah.
So now walk up and grab her tits unless she tells you to
be safe.
And don't do it.
Ever walked those titties and get your fucking hands and then take a stroll in
the snow.
And then why do you know you're gonna fuck her in the ass?
It's a most wonderful time.
Oh Wow.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's built births.
The Monday morning podcast for Monday,
December six 2010 how come I can't fucking hear myself going on here.
Hello.
Yo Mother fucker.
What is going on?
Hello?
Hello.
All the levels seem right.
The fuck am I doing wrong lately?
I used to have this shit down.
Wow.
I hope it's all right because it's late in the day and I have a football game to
watch.
Patriots are playing the jets.
You know,
those two fucking teams up and talking about for fucking 19 weeks in a row.
Uh,
they're playing tonight.
So I got fucking hustle through this thing because I'm doing this thing late
cause I just flew back from San Francisco.
I left my balls,
San Francisco.
Isn't that how the song goes?
Tony Bennett comes out,
luck be a lady two nights.
Um,
that's Frank Sinatra.
Go Fuck yourself there.
Crooner fans.
What do think about that during the holiday month,
as you can tell,
I,
um,
I blew out my voice when I was doing cobb's club up in,
uh,
San Francisco and a,
I had a great fucking time.
I'm 51 days without drinking and I gotta tell you that's,
um,
San Francisco was one of those cities that makes you want to drink.
You know,
it's just an awesome city.
You go up there,
uh,
that's two weekends in a row.
I've absolutely loved the city Seattle last week and now San Francisco this week
in San Francisco.
It was really,
I don't know how people stay sober there because every time you walk around the
corner you just see one of those bars.
You know,
it's just got that warm old
dingy,
but it's got some character and he just want to fucking go in there and get a
pint and just start talking some shit.
You know,
it's fucking cold and rainy there the whole fucking weekend.
So site to be back in La those first time.
I've seen the sun in like 10 fucking days.
It feels like the meet with the potty mouth this week.
Um,
but anyways,
yeah,
it was up there and I work cobb's comedy club and I want to thank all those
people who came out to see me.
It was ridiculous turnout.
A Cobbs is a,
uh,
it's a giant room for a comedy club and the place was packed the entire weekend.
And uh,
it was great.
Everybody was showing up.
Bunch of people came up and told me that they love the podcast and I had like
five people come up to me and tell me how much they liked the Socorro,
what they love it.
So I'm thinking actually turning that into a bit,
sticking into my act.
Um,
I just don't know if it's going to work because,
uh,
I think maybe if I stick my mouth close enough actually,
you know,
and I listen,
listen back to the podcast,
it's sounded like the,
uh,
it sounded like the same sort of distortion.
I got to try it out.
I really got to fucking try it out.
You know what?
There's a room out here called the comedy union.
Uh,
used to be called mixed nuts.
It's called the comedy union is down on Labrea and uh,
well it's awful.
The Brayer can't remember.
It's right down the street from,
uh,
Roscoe's waffle house,
chicken and waffles.
Roscoe's chicken and waffles.
Huh?
African Americans.
You listening to the podcast as a big shout out to that fucking restaurant.
Uh,
but anyways,
it's a club.
Um,
you know,
any comedian can go down there,
but it's a predominantly black audience.
Remember that from the news,
these to say that all the time,
a predominantly black neighborhood,
predominantly black
neighborhood.
So that's like what the crowds are.
So whenever I have a joke like that,
I like to go down to rooms like that or maybe do Tuesday night at the comedy
store because I want to make sure that I'm saying the shit the right way.
You know,
granted that opens the door to some awkwardness if it doesn't come off the right
way.
But that's the fun of doing what I do.
So maybe I'm going to head down there and speaking of Roscoe's chicken and
Waffles,
I heard so much about that shit.
A so called white man heard so much about that ship from the predominantly black
comedians
always hyping that place up.
You gotta go down there.
You got to go down there and I got to tell you something.
I like chicken and I like Waffles,
but I do not like that shit together.
All right.
At no point in my life did syrup ever need to touch a chicken?
It's a,
it's fucking gross.
And uh,
I went there once and I'll never go there again.
It was one of those,
uh,
you ever go to like a soul food place and it's like fucking like hardcore
African American and you feel foolish as you're ordering cause everything's
named after like some civil rights leader.
Uh,
you know,
Roscoe's chicken and waffles going to take you on it.
Yeah.
Let me get the Frederick Douglas a Chili fries.
Ed.
Can I get the,
uh,
Medgar Evers,
at a mommy?
Whatever the fuck.
Um,
you just feel dumb saying so,
and I don't know if it's that bad.
Where the fuck was that Amy Ruth's?
We're going back in my career here.
Back in my career when I used to,
uh,
I used to fucking jump over on both sides of the fence,
all the God damn time back in the good old days.
That was always a period in my career where I made sure that I,
uh,
on a regular basis when I was trying to figure out how to say what,
you know,
these glorious Dick Jokes and shit jokes that I do on stage.
There was a period during my career when I would,
when I would,
uh,
I would do all the rooms,
I could get in front of all the crowds.
And if you're a comedian,
I suggest that you do that because it can do nothing but help you.
And,
um,
you know,
if you're really,
you know what I mean?
I learned that shit.
Cause I saw Eddie Murphy on the raw tour way back in the day.
I saw Rodney Dangerfield,
danger fields.
There was two of them,
Rodney Dangerfield.
And then two weeks later,
I say Eddie Murphy on the raw tour.
And I was like,
fuck at 18 years old.
And I remember looking at Eddie's crowd versus,
uh,
Rodney's crowd.
And for some fucking reason that just clicked to me.
Like Rodney's hilarious.
But Eddie is making everybody laugh.
So I remember,
uh,
kind of knew I wanted to be a comedian at that point,
but it took me another few years to get the balls,
you know,
to go on stage.
And then I'll say,
I had this fucking thing in my head that,
you know,
I had to make sure I finished college,
got to make sure I got tens of thousands of dollars worth of deck worth of debt.
So then I can then go on stage and talk about my Dick,
right.
To make my life even more difficult.
Um,
look,
I'm not saying whether or not you should go to college or you shouldn't,
but,
uh,
if you will like me and you just fucking knew,
you know,
you looked at standup comedy and you just,
you just fucking knew.
Uh,
I don't think it would be the worst thing if he just said to hell with the next,
you know,
$40,000 worth of debt.
But who the fuck am I?
Who am I to say that?
How far we ended it us seven minutes then seven fucking minutes.
And I could tell you,
oh my God,
I'm fucking red line.
And on this shit here.
Um,
seven minutes in.
I don't think I have anything left to talk about.
I am so fucking frazzled because I,
I don't know what happens when I fly back on the day of a podcast that you just,
I don't have any funny,
is no funny in me right now.
I'm just sitting here like I might as well be on meet the press.
You don't talking about budgets for the upcoming fiscal year?
Uh,
um,
did anything interesting happened to me in San Francisco?
Of course not.
I wasn't drinking.
I'll tell you that I went out and I,
yeah,
I tried a bunch of food up there and I'll,
this is something I can guarantee you.
All right.
If you like a Burrito,
go to San Francisco.
Those guys,
I had a Burrito when I was up in San Francisco.
I've been thinking about,
I'm always fucking thinking about it before he even said what I just said,
I've been thinking about this shit.
Like,
you know,
you have of just bang some fucking just,
some girl you never got to marry,
but she,
I don't know what she does.
I don't want to get graphic.
I try to stay away from the SEC ship,
but you know,
and you just can't stop fucking thinking and your brain's going,
don't go back to her.
She's out of her fucking mind.
She's a,
that's not a mother.
That's not a mom.
You're not going to marry.
You don't fucking go back.
But what she did on the other side,
right.
Come on.
We're all adults.
You know what I'm talking.
You can't stop fucking ticket about it.
I had the food version of that and God damn it,
it was a Burrito in San Francisco and like a fucking asshole.
I can't even tell you where I got it.
Uh,
I guess I can go a,
I can go on the Internet here and try and find it.
By the way,
here's a youtube video for you.
I'm a huge Stevie Ray Vaughan fan.
Huge Stevie Ray Vaughan Fan.
And,
uh,
he did a cover of an Albert King song called eight.
I just say,
ain't gonna give up on love,
but it's ain't gone and give up on love.
Uh,
I'm too white to say it that way.
So I say,
I ain't going to give up on love.
And the guy who put it up is a SRV music like Stevie Ray Vaughan music video,
SRV music video.
Um,
you put it up like a year ago for some reason I missed it.
And uh,
you got to see this.
If you're a fan of guitar playing,
even if you don't like Blues Guitar,
Stevie Ray Vaughn,
he gets like three quarters of the way through his second blistering solo and he
fucking does this little spin move on,
does the fucking guitar straps and unal the guitars behind him,
straps the fucking guitar back on and proceeds to finish the solo behind his
back.
And not only is he playing with the guitar behind his back,
he takes the solo to a whole level beyond the Stevie Ray Vaughan level.
He was just at,
it's the fucking,
like if somebody could show me anybody who can play behind their back with that
level of passion,
that fucking good.
I mean,
I don't even know if Hendrix could do that.
Hendrix used to fucking,
I mean,
I know Hendrix is a better fucking guitarist.
I'm not even going to start that fucking argument.
All right.
That's like compare and Jordan to Decoby.
I get it.
I'm not even trying to say it before we even have this fucking argument.
Jimmy is,
yeah,
you can't even touch that guy.
But I'm just saying he took that,
that you know,
that stage trick to a whole nother fucking let's watch it.
And actually if you can find me one,
uh,
Jimmy doing it better,
which I'm sure you can,
maybe I haven't looked hard enough.
I'd love to see it because I get fucking chills watching this shit.
So anyways,
I'm going to,
uh,
I'm going to get rid of this screen here.
I'm going to find the name of this fucking burrito place cause it was,
it was fucking amazing.
Um,
now I can't look for this as I'm doing this podcast.
Isn't this going to get boring for you guys?
Huh?
How's,
I'm typing with my middle finger.
Cisco,
you're,
it's funny about people in San Francisco at where every time I go there and
somewhere I either read or somebody tells me that nobody calls the city San
Fran.
And I really want to tell him that nobody I know calls it San Fran.
We just say San Francisco.
We don't call it Frisco either.
Like you fucking hit people in San Francisco.
We don't call it.
We just say San San Francisco.
Go to San Francisco.
I wouldn't say I'm going to shy instead of Chicago would I?
I guess people say shy town.
All right,
here we go.
I am fucking zeroing in where I got this God Damn Burrito.
I'm going to find that somebody wanted to satellite like the fucking Illuminati
does.
You know that when this staring at you watching your fucking rubbing one out,
saving the video.
So if you ever go against,
all right,
it's on,
uh,
you motherfucker,
give me the satellite.
Come on,
give me that shit.
Don't you like how the Illuminati is allowed us to do this too so it won't seem
as creepy when they'd fucking do it to us.
Is that it?
All right.
There you go.
I got it.
It's on a you can't you fuck it.
Can't,
there it is right there.
It's on ninth avenue and Irving Street.
All right.
Just beyond Yancey saloon on that side of the road,
you walk down,
you make a right on nine fucking avenue.
Now I'm going to take the little yellow man.
The little Asian Dude,
right?
Is that it was supposed to be.
Huh?
Put them down on the street.
Look at me and there's where the fuck I was.
Slowly going down the street isn't as exciting,
isn't this?
This is what you get when you get a free fucking podcast.
You get absolutely no.
Look at a poodle that the satellite took a picture of.
You think it's still alive.
It's one of those bigger poodles.
You know like the George Meichin have poodles.
You know those big ones?
They're actually really good at Frisbee.
They actually become a dog when they get that big.
All right,
where the fuck is it?
You fucking whore.
Don't be like this.
I don't fucking know.
I told you basically where it is and it's on the fucking west side of the
street.
Anyways,
I had a god Damn Burrito.
I'm still thinking about it.
And here I am in the middle of the podcast doing one of the most boring things I
could possibly do is,
which is search for the thing.
That's how good this fucking Burrito was.
I've literally stocking it just so I can stand outside the window via my fucking
laptop.
All right?
That was excrutiatingly boring.
And if this podcast wasn't free,
I'd fucking apologize for uh,
[inaudible].
So,
Hey,
I got a letter here for some,
a fan from Alaska.
All right?
You ever hear that expression where they say you can't run from your problems?
Well,
uh,
tell people in Alaska,
because most people up there are wanted,
you know,
and not in a good way.
Like,
we really love you to come back to South Dakota.
They are wanted in
one of those,
you know,
like you know those fucking idiots,
those spur of the moment,
bank robbers,
we stand in there and the only reason why you robbed the bank was because the
line was just long enough to give you enough time to think like,
you know what?
I could always rob does fucking bank and if there was no one in front of you,
you just want it gone in and found out what you know,
what your balance was.
But there was just,
you know,
seven people in front of you.
You started working out the whole thing.
You know the fuck's going on.
Look at everybody.
We all work every single day and every week they give us a check.
They don't give us cash.
They give us a check.
They give us these numbers on a piece of paper.
What do we deal with that?
We take it right down to these clients.
We give them all our money.
You know,
it's,
is this,
I feel like a fucking hooker right now.
I went out and I worked,
all right.
I get my money in this form fucking currency that I can't,
I can't even use unless I go to you.
You fucking asshole.
And then you keep the shit.
I got to stick it in there and you give it out to be $20 at a time telling me
everything's gonna be okay.
I want you to know something.
I would love to go to a bank where they actually had the nerve to walk around
and like purple sparkly suits with big feathers,
you know,
driving Lincoln continentals from 1975.
Just dress like the fucking pimp that you are.
I'll give a shit.
I'll doll myself up to go in there and try and get my money.
You fucking cunts.
So anyways,
this is a,
uh,
um,
a letter from a crazy Alaskan fan set,
a pill I bought,
let it go on Itunes,
um,
earlier this evening and had,
uh,
quite the fucking goat rope.
I don't know what that means.
I'm,
I'm sure that means like,
I was freaking out in Alaska.
I had quite the fucking goat rope.
The fuck would that mean the Italia go to your cabin up there.
Goats eat everything.
I don't,
I don't get it.
Crazy Alaskan fan.
Can you please explain that to me?
I don't know.
You had quite the fucking goat rope.
Okay.
That doesn't sound like it was good.
Um,
anyways,
I live out in the middle of BFE Alaska.
I don't know what that means.
Either set up an area or is that bum fucking East Alaska?
I don't know.
And have no need for the Internet in my Ted Kaczynski Cabin,
according to mark Marin on Twitter,
uh,
Ted Kaczynski is a cabin is actually for sale.
Um,
but I digress.
Here we go.
Continuing my neighbor who is down the road has,
has the Internet and if I sit my laptop sideways facing due south on the very
top of my Warren commission volumes,
I can connect at tip top 1997 speed.
I only do this once a month.
So I went on iTunes and I bought let it go,
Joe to Rosen's album,
the depression auction and some Chuck Berry.
You've got great taste too.
Great Comedians and one of the greatest guitarists of all time.
Um,
all right,
Michael Graves.
I Dunno what that,
if I'm saying that right,
and the latest iron maiden effort,
I picked all the tunes out that I wanted sat my laptop on.
It's seven foot perch on its side so I could download,
let it go so I could let it download all that shit.
All right.
I sat down and out of the corner of my eye,
I saw Sarah mcglothlin written on the screen and I immediately thought,
Oh fuck,
I somehow hit the wrong button and I fucking bought some Sarah McLaughlin Song.
Uh,
so I grabbed the for the computer and there it went right down to the fucking
floor,
seven feet down onto a linoleum for boom.
I started screaming at the top of my lungs about that cut Sarah McLaughlin and
those prick bastards that iTunes for faking me out and make me buy that dumb
shit.
I was really freaking out.
I open my front door to cool off and therefore feet in front of me was a big
brown bear looking at me like I was some kind of asshole.
I grabbed the door and ran like hell back in Lik lickety split lickety split.
And that's the kind of fucking expression you use if you live in a cap fucking
goat rope.
Lickety split.
Uh,
my heart was beating like crazy.
I was surprised to see,
and I walked up to my computer and I was surprised to see that my screen was
okay on the laptop.
It fired right up away.
Holy Shit.
It works.
When I reloaded Itunes,
I saw Sarah,
Sarah McLaughlin was actually one of the comedy cuts on let it go.
Uh,
I let it go.
All right,
you're crazy.
Alaskan fant Pete Jesus Christ piece.
It sounds like some shit I would do you guys that a lot.
Do you absolutely lose your shit.
You know,
you build up some,
some sort of conspiracy in your fucking head and then you realize in the end
that you were actually wrong.
You know,
but in that moment you by yourself and you try to blow it off by turning the car
radio on and try to drown out that voice that's screaming voice in your head and
that feeling of embarrassment that you,
you were actually the Douche bag and then he just wasted the last whatever,
five,
seven minutes of your life.
Absolute flipping out about some shit that you know,
really didn't,
didn't even fucking happen or maybe some shit that you created.
If you did,
then you can relate to the first 37 years of my life people.
Cause that's what the fuck I did.
My God damn fingernails,
I need to cut my fingernails.
I've been on the road too.
God Damn long it guys.
Is it okay if I just tap out?
Can I just,
you know,
you know what I feel like right now when you guys are at work and you just don't
want to be there.
So then you just,
you start faking sick.
You know,
you get that Douchey look on your face,
you know,
and you know,
you just start speaking in a whiny softly can't,
ain't,
don't really see is neat boss.
Excuse me.
Yeah,
I don't,
I don't know if it's something I ate.
I started feeling like this the other day.
You always have to give it credibility.
I started feeling this way the other day.
Really?
You were pretty fucking chipper when he came walking in.
You know I me tell you guys about that coke head I used to work with a long time
ago,
used to come walking into the warehouse like four hours late on a sunny day with
his hair soaking wet from the shower and his excuse was always the same.
Oh,
the traffic traffic was unbelievable.
Really?
It's fucking 92 degrees out there buddy.
With your soak and wet hair.
I don't even know if it was from a shower.
Could have been like that drug sweat.
What time I was doing the opiate Anthony's show and they had some guys,
some fucking rock band guys in there that will the shit,
I'm not gonna fucking blow up the spot.
And say their name because it was like eight 30 in the morning when they came
in.
We interviewed them for like an hour and at nine 30 in the morning I asked the
lead singer if I can get a picture with them and he goes,
sure.
He fucking pulled me into him at his head,
fucking side of his face up against my side of the face.
And it was just,
I don't know what it was.
Flop sweat,
drug,
sweat,
meth,
sweat.
I don't know what the fuck it was.
But you have,
if you have a fucking play basketball and you play shirts and skins and the
fatty,
not only you gotta cover the fatty,
but he fucking is skins and they're in that transition games and you fucking
just standing there and the paint and that fatty goes running by you and you
feel like,
ah,
like somebody just emptied a Jacuzzi on you.
That's what it felt like was fucking disgusting.
Oh wait a minute.
There it is.
There's the Burrito spot.
It's called Gordo,
There we go.
On Ninth Avenue in Irving.
Just walk North on Ninth Avenue.
Irving street was the fucking shit.
It's one of those things.
If I was like Elvis Presley,
you know I,
hi my house,
go get a fucking burrito man.
I'm all hopped up on coils and shit.
I want to fucking Burrito man.
I would get him a private jet van Nuys and I'd fly like nine of my friends up
who don't really like me and at that point that just there for the money and
they'll laugh at it.
All my jokes like I'm the funniest fuck or wherever,
you know I am.
I am.
Where'd you get those shoes?
At a shoe store and they're all like,
wow,
you killed us to kill us.
I know,
man.
Everything I say it's funny.
Everything.
Everything I sing is a fucking hit.
Let's go get a fucking burrito.
That steward,
he's thinks you'll suck my dick.
Everybody laughing like sexual sexual harassment didn't exist back then.
If you sold enough fucking records in the 70s sexual harassment didn't exist in
the 60s yeah,
you could just,
you could just rape somebody if you had a hit record,
if anybody complained,
ah,
pipe down.
How many albums did you sell there,
sweetheart?
It's a brutal fucking time to be a female,
you know?
So we had to correct it.
And the only way we knew we would have known,
we never would have found out if those ladies didn't start burning their bras.
How many of those fucking ex hippies do you think that regret that moment?
Standing in the street?
What?
What exactly was their fucking problem with the presenter?
You know,
what do you want?
You want your titties hanging down to your waist.
You don't want that.
The number one fucking thing that gets you some shit.
Little things during the course of the day.
Oh Man.
Would you like to go first?
Go ahead.
You think I'm being a gentleman?
I'm not being a gentleman.
It's cause you have perky titties.
All right?
And you had the fucking decency to only button your shirt right up to just below
your cleavage.
And because of that.
Yes,
madam,
you can go before me,
if I had a hat,
I would take it off and I would bend over at the waist like,
like,
like one of those three musketeers,
you know,
throw my fucking coat down over a puddle of water.
You know that you are ma'am.
Right?
Cause he had Teddy's,
what keeps you Teddy's parky ladies.
What keeps him yeah.
Side from eating steamed vegetables instead of a quarter pounder with cheese.
Come on.
We all know shit.
Goddamn.
Birzir all right,
Si.
Si fucking the Sports Bra.
Whatever the fuck you want.
If you want to keep those babies high and tight.
All right.
And I know it's hard for you to hear this from a man he's coming off showed
chauvinistically right?
If I was,
you know,
some fucking motivational speaker and I was a female standing up here saying the
exact same shit,
but I had a clam,
you'd be listening,
you'd be listening you by my stupid books and I'd have those fucking arm smart
glasses on,
you know,
you know those women dress,
they walked that fine line of having a business suit on.
But they still look like,
you know,
I'll fuck the shit out of you.
You know that look,
exactly.
Speaking of that,
you guys seen that fuck.
And I'm walking around right now.
I got to stand up.
Let the funny fall down.
Wash over me.
You guys watched that show up.
I don't know what the hell it's called,
but you know what I mean?
That's it's,
it's stars,
this woman.
Um,
it's kind of like that Shana.
Let's show that bald guys screaming about the stocks and he's throwing stuffed
animals around it for some stupid fucking reason.
People that I know why people listen because he's loud.
He's passionate.
I've made a fucking career out of that.
If you just say my jokes without screaming them in working up a sweat,
I don't think that that funny,
you know,
the true masters to bill,
Bill Cosby can sit in a lawn chair and kill for two straight hours.
I couldn't do that.
Jesus Christ.
If I sat down for two hours to try to tell jokes,
just the sound of my own voice with that put me asleep again about the fucking
crowd.
But anyways,
so I'm watching the show late night cause I'm not drinking,
you know,
staying in this fucking hotel down on Jefferson Street and hide the Apocalypto,
whatever the fuck it's called.
You know what's funny?
I think I took a picture to them and to put it on the [inaudible] podcast.com
for some fucking reason.
Did you guys ever see that movie a Shaka Zulu that the name of it?
Chuck a Zulu,
Shaka Zulu Zulu for Hulu,
whatever the fuck it's called,
right?
It was basically about a Ah,
gee,
I don't know what the fuck was abuzz about English guys in Africa.
And they went down there and uh,
they took over some shit and the Zulu nation and had enough right
and a,
they all stood on the fucking hill and that they had this slamming their fucking
weapons against their,
uh,
their shields.
That's the shit.
You know,
Michael Caine and all those guys.
You remember how they were dressed?
No stupid white hats.
I don't know what,
I don't know what it looked like.
You know what it looked like?
You might have you guys ever watch bonanza?
Remember that guy,
hos where that 10 gallon fucking hat.
Just imagine if you had that hat,
but you cut the brim off of it.
He just left that big stupid hat on.
Amy,
you've got a little bit of a brim on the front and on the back.
Like if,
uh,
what do you call those?
Those little hats.
You know those little hats that fucking people were like Charlie Chaplin.
Just imagine if that had,
could get an erection right in the fucking brim was the balls.
So you know that just fucking stay in the same,
that's what the hat look like.
Okay.
For some fucked up reason.
The,
the,
I was going to say the guards,
the dudes who stand outside on the sidewalk and go,
hey,
can I help you with that bag that you obviously carried here with no problems so
I can possibly make a couple of dollars.
Those guys,
the doorman,
they it go,
they were dressed like those fucking Englishman and uh,
Shaka Zulu or chuck or Zulu,
Zulu,
Hulu,
whatever the fuck it's called.
I Dunno why I thought to need to bring that up.
Well,
let's talk about the hotel.
They had a wine tasting place right next door,
you know,
which just attracts soccer moms.
It's fucking ridiculous.
You know those Goddamn broads,
when they get older,
they have a couple of kids,
they can't go out and do keg stands with their,
who ha hanging out of their panties anymore.
They're a fucking mom.
So they gotta be,
you know,
they've got to be more mature with their drinking.
So they go out to places like those little,
those wine bars.
Husic isn't too loud,
you know,
it doesn't make their tits quiver.
Right.
So they can sit down,
sit down with their friends,
they have cheese,
they got wine,
and they could sit there and discuss shit,
you know,
and act like they're fucking adults rather than just scared teenagers with
children.
Um,
the fuck.
So I had to walk by that shit all the time and evidently one of these broads had
too much to drink.
I don't know what somebody's fucking yakked on my floor.
It was cleaned up before I got there.
But she know that,
you know,
once somebody pukes that it's just going to be there.
It's going to be there for what you need.
You need a new rug who's getting no.
All right.
If you puke enough,
they really need to tear down the building.
So anyways,
I know I got an that fucking subject,
but this is good man.
I got a little bit of momentum.
I stood up feeling.
All right.
Oh,
I know what I was talking about.
I was talking about that lady I was watching on the show.
So uh oh,
I'm not drinking salt back in the hotel where the dude's address,
like the fucking apartheid Englishman at the door and somebody yakked on my
floor.
I'm sitting there watching this fucking show.
That's how I got there.
All right,
so I'm watching the show and a flipping through the channels and watching TV and
I'm flipping through the fucking channels.
I'm losing all my,
God damn bet someone one in three this week.
I'm not flipping through the fucking channels.
And I stopped on this show
and it's this lady,
I don't know what her deal is,
but like adults call her up and say,
I want to buy this.
Can I afford it?
You know,
like they're fucking eight years old.
Just call.
Hey,
see is,
and this is,
this is jail.
I'm calling in from Arkansas for thoughts.
You want to tell you I love your show.
I absolutely love it.
Me and my husband,
we watch it all the time.
We absolutely love it.
We think you're great.
And you know,
a lot of people probably think that you put too much bleach on your teeth,
especially with that orange fake Tan,
you know,
so you look like that fucking plant in little shop of horrors.
But that's not me.
I think you look great,
right?
They go through all that bullshit.
So this bitch calls up in though.
Why do I say that?
I never talked to women that way.
So this lady says,
I want a fucking,
uh,
I went,
I want to buy,
uh,
I want to buy a fucking condo down in Florida.
Do I have enough money?
Do I have it?
Can I have 40 that's what the fuck she said called up.
This complete fucking stranger says,
I want to buy a condo and ass.
This other fucking complete fucking stranger.
Can I afford it?
It's like,
did you mail this woman all your bank records like five fucking years ago and
you haven't,
you have no fucking idea how much money you have.
You dumb cunts.
Jesus,
what?
The whole fucking hour was.
Hey,
my name's Mike.
I'm calling in from Rhode Island.
Listen,
I want to get a tattoo on my fucking ball bag,
but I also want to cut out the rope so I can get tee tops.
Oh my fucking 85 rally sport.
Can I afford to do that?
That's what the show was.
This woman telling adults
who had jobs and lives and probably children,
whether or not they could afford something.
It just really was.
You know,
that was one of those times where it's just like,
you know what,
there's not enough lightning in the world.
You know?
Just as far as the odds of being struck by lightning.
We need to bring that average up because the amount of fucking morons out there
versus actually intelligent people,
you're going to hit a fucking moron,
you know basically going to hit a moron or are you going to hit the ocean?
Those are going to be the top two in that order.
Even though the fucking world is three quarters fucking water,
you still got a higher chance as lightening to fucking hit a moron.
That's that.
That's,
I'm telling you,
that's my goddamn theory and that's what I want the new staff to be.
Rather than being like,
you know,
the,
the odds of getting hit by lightening are higher up than Blah,
blah,
blah.
I want it to turn into,
I want so much lightening that,
that,
that the new stat is the odds of an intelligent person actually being hit by
lightening are x,
y,
and Z.
Do you like how in my own little style in esque world that I'm actually
intelligent and everybody else is just a sea of morons?
Huh?
You don't have thoughts like that.
Murderous thoughts.
I was actually talking to this broad up in,
uh,
San Francisco and
I got this whole chunk about hitting women that I've been doing on stage.
And,
uh,
it's actually something embarrassing I have to admit about myself as much as I
do the,
the comedy thing for a living.
I'm really bad at picking up on sarcasm.
I don't know why I use sarcasm.
I'm sarcastic,
right?
But for some reason when someone uses it against me,
I,
I like that old guy downstairs.
But if I told you that shit last year and I was dragging my Christmas tree down
the stairs,
he stuck his head out the window and he just goes,
beautiful morning,
isn't it?
And he had this fucked up look on his face,
but he said,
beautiful morning,
isn't it?
So I was confused and I just went,
yeah,
it is a beautiful morning.
I don't think of,
why is he yelling with that,
twist it up,
looking his face.
And then I walked around the corner.
I was like,
oh,
he didn't mean it.
He,
what he really meant was she making a lot of fucking noise ruining this
beautiful morning.
So he got me.
Then I always end up feeling stupid.
So you know,
I'm doing this whole chunk on hitting the broads over there.
Right.
And I'm standing afterwards whoring myself out,
right.
Selling my DVD,
showed a little bit of leg doing what I gotta do and this fucking woman is
walking out in,
her husband has sort of shuffling her out and she starts going,
ah,
oh yeah,
she,
she has has once again the twist it up,
look on her face.
She goes,
thanks for the domestic violence jokes.
I really appreciated it.
I really appreciated the domestic violence.
Jux thanks a lot for the domestic violence jokes.
That's what she was doing.
And because she was saying thanks,
it just,
it went totally past my head.
I was more just confused by her facial expression.
So she said he called.
Yeah.
I really appreciate it.
Thanks a lot.
I'm literally just waving gone.
Alright,
glad you enjoyed the shop.
Which is funny because it probably pissed her off more,
but I was sincerely thanking her completely missing her sarcasm.
What she was really saying was ivy that dealt with that personally or that's
happening to somebody right now or has happened to someone or I grew up with it
or whatever,
and you brought up bad memories and you ruined my fucking evening.
That's what she was really saying.
But of course I took it at face value,
which actually when I look back on it,
I think makes it even funnier because who's kidding who?
She already thinks I'm a fucking moron at that point,
you know?
So it would actually would have made her a little bit happier if I tried to
appear intelligent.
If like actually you missed the point of the geocode.
It was really trying to do is expose the hypocrisy of us,
some of the relationships between the male and female fixes.
If I went that route,
you know,
okay,
then she could have gotten this hot.
But the fact that I literally was the moron that she thought I was,
and then that there was this whole line of people,
you know what,
I just realized I should be struck by lightning.
Where the fuck is wrong with me?
I'm one of those fucking morons.
Um,
all right,
so there's that portion of the fucking program that's 36 minutes.
Do it.
I'm not,
there's no way.
I'm going more than 50 minutes.
I got to make a judgment call here.
Like,
uh,
I'm trying to find some friends where I can watch his patriots jets game cause
I,
I can't go out and watch just regular games at a sports bar unless it's a team I
don't give a fuck about,
but there's no way,
uh,
a game like this that I care so much about.
Um,
I know too,
a lot of people,
this is going to be a huge fucking game,
which obviously it is,
but I gotta be honest with you.
I,
I'm not feeling our defense.
I really want to talk some shit,
but I gotta be honest with you.
Okay?
You guys want to hear my big prediction.
I'm going to go on a limb here rather than all these other fucking assholes who
email me after the game and don't make any sort of predictions.
This is my prediction.
I think
obviously you guys know I don't like our fucking defense,
but I gotta I gotta tell you this.
We have no fucking pass rush and the jets haven't fucking incredible offensive
line.
Those guys are the shit.
So what's his face?
Sanchez is going to be sitting back there like bill Cosby doing a standup
special.
Um,
and then you combine the fact that with that we have a shit defense that lets up
24 to 30 fucking points a game.
I don't like that aspect of it,
but I believe in our offense.
I think our offense is great,
but they have a great defense.
So I dunno,
I just really see this being one of those 28 to 17 you know,
don't listen to my gambling tips.
But if I was gambling,
I actually had to put money on this.
It was my last fucking 100 bucks.
I would,
I would take the jets in the fucking points,
but uh,
but if the Patriots do win because we got fucking Tom Brady and we have the
genius of Bill Bellacheck who can somehow figure out a way during the second
half to come back.
I think,
uh,
even if they win,
I still don't think it means shit other than that.
We've come a long way since September,
but we'd still have to,
I think write,
we'd still have to play
that.
I Dunno.
Then if the play offs came around,
I had a playoffs.
I don't know.
This game is going to be fucking awesome.
Plus you also got to look at,
but uh,
Rex Ryan has Buddy Ryan at his fingertips.
So this dog,
this is going to be a fucking awesome game.
This is really going to be an awesome game and I am going to age at least eight
fucking years.
I'm not gonna be able to handle it.
Like I got to tell you some games like I,
this is how fucking psycho I get.
Like I give a shit so much.
Sometimes I taped the game and I don't even watch it.
And then I just find out if my team wins,
then I'll sit down and watch it.
But if they lose,
I just fucking erase the game because that,
that's how much it affects me,
you know?
And I know what you think.
Oh,
what are you a fucking pussy?
Yes.
I don't know if a pussy up from fucking intelligent.
It's like I don't want,
I don't want to waste that amount of my fucking life.
I don't want to care that much,
but I do.
So I try to protect myself.
Oh,
so let me tell you guys about San Francisco.
If you go into San Francisco,
if you're going to San Francisco,
um,
here's some shit to know.
Their public transportation system takes,
it takes a minute to kind of get to figure it out.
They have like all these different subway lines that they're like street cars
and then they go underground ground.
They all sort of funnel inter down there.
The Union Square area,
the Union Square area,
as far as I can tell,
is the most touristy fucking place.
Like the Times Square of San Francisco in that,
I don't think anybody from San Francisco goes there.
I think people from Oakland go in it.
Douche bags like me go down there before they figure out like,
oh,
this place sucks.
But,
uh,
I actually,
if the line's not too long and you can jump on one of those rice,
a Roni trolleys and he can go all the way up to fucking north beach and hang on,
who do we got here?
Ah,
Jesus.
He says,
the guy's calling about the game.
Hey Ben,
I'm doing my podcast.
Let me call you back in like 20 minutes.
All right.
All right,
cool.
Um,
all right.
Yeah.
So I don't know if you go there with you girl is all the shops it down there.
So you're going to want to go,
they already told you where to get a burrito.
Actually,
if you just want to go to Burrito ground central,
go to go to a,
the mission district.
And this is just for people if you're going to San Francisco.
And then there's just all kinds of fucking awesome bars.
And I actually was staying.
Uh,
you know what?
It fucking rained the entire time I was there.
Where else did I go?
I got some decent Italian food.
I went to that place,
Mama's for breakfast.
I wasn't really impressed,
but I got French toast and I figured most people don't.
You know,
something that's something that a lot of people don't know how to make.
I can actually make better French toast than most of the fucking assholes out
there.
You know,
they just don't do it right.
They just don't fucking do it right.
The bread just doesn't taste right.
I go old fashioned way.
My mom used to make it,
you know,
you actually use white bread that Wonderbread shit.
And I know it's a lower quality meat,
a fucking bread than they use.
But I'm telling you,
sometimes you can overthink something.
He get to fucking fancy.
I've gotta tell you right now,
you go out and make yourself a fried egg.
You fry it up and butter.
All right.
Fuck the surgeon general.
Every once in a while you've got to tell that guy to stand the fuck down.
All right,
sit out.
Oh man,
I'm cooking this shit and butter,
right?
With your stupid fucking half a beard
surgeon general looks like you already fucking die.
Did he die?
We had that like,
like he was the commander in chief of all love boats.
That fucking uniform.
Um,
so whatever you fry it up in butter.
All right,
you cook it over Eg.
Daikin,
Eg.
All right.
Cook it over easy.
I don't know how to fuck you guys do it.
When I do something over easy,
I fucking uh,
I turned the egg once.
All right,
after I cook the fucking egg and I get it to the consistency.
I want what?
I cook it on low heat too,
by the way,
Ron,
she'll cook Christ your cook that shit out of it.
Um,
you cook it on a low heat,
right?
And then once you do is once you get it looking the way you want it to look,
y'all see,
put your salt and pepper on the top right as it's fucking cooking in the butter.
Then you flip it over and the second you flip it over,
you take it off the heat.
All right?
And you let,
how hot the uh,
the pan already is cooked the other side.
All right,
so almost like mark and a steak.
That's how you do the other side.
That way you get the egg isn't runny,
you know,
but you still got the yolk there.
All right,
well that's how I make an egg over easy.
But if I'm making a fucking fried egg,
you know,
you've got to cook a thing over heart.
Same Shit.
You Cook it in butter.
Sit the fuck down old man.
He kicked you cook it in butter and he'd do that.
All that bullshit and you just,
you want wonder bread.
You want the shittiest fucking bread ever.
All right?
That kind of shit that you're not going to digest.
See like 62 slices a wonder bread.
All right,
you salt and pepper.
That bitch.
She cook it in fucking butter.
You put it on the God damn sandwich and he put a little mustard on top of it.
Nothing fucking fancy that,
that grey poupon shit.
I'm talking broke ass white trash.
Fucking my mustard.
All right.
Yellow plastic container comes out yellow like mustard.
Should be not that golden shit.
None of that stuff.
Straight up.
All right?
You fucking,
you know,
put that bitch on a plate and you go to Tom Delicious,
straight up fucking comfort food,
all those fucking places.
I don't know why they don't just make shit like that.
Just,
you know,
it's like the Mcdonald's concept,
but you actually use sort of real food.
I was speaking to that,
you know,
when I was walking through Haight Ashbury or the hate,
you don't want to get a fucking look like,
oh,
you're a tourist.
Just say,
I want to go to the hate.
How did we get to the hate?
Right?
You go to fucking,
and I don't,
what the fuck?
I still feel stupid saying that.
Uh,
but you go out there,
you know,
and that's where all the dirty white people are.
Hey Man,
can you spare Asian folk can change me in.
And they got dreadlocks and shit,
you know,
dirty fucking wrangler jeans from sitting on the fucking sidewalk.
I really am reverse racist when it comes to fucking,
uh,
white homeless people,
you know?
Okay.
If you're white and you're fucking homeless and you're under the age of 62
you're not getting a fucking dime out of me.
You just knocked unless you,
maybe if you're a female,
then he got that look.
You know you got that right.
Look,
I'll do it,
you know?
But other than that,
it's like,
come on man,
seriously get a fucking job.
You're a fucking white dude.
Go get a fucking job.
I really shouldn't be making those jokes in this economy.
I apologize,
but you know what I'm saying?
All right,
talking about,
I'm not talking about you.
If you're out of work right now and you're looking for a job,
hang in there.
I fucking respect.
You're right.
But I'm talking about those other bumps.
Talking about bumps in their 20s all right,
this is a deal.
If you're white,
if you look like boxcar Willie,
you know you've got to stick with that little kerchief tattoo it.
I'll give you some money.
You know,
if you could stick IOM nose in your mouth because you don't have any fucking
teeth,
I'll give you some money.
You know what?
As far as the rest of the people go,
you get money out of me.
If you look like you're sober,
other than that,
you can go fuck yourself,
whatever.
Hap Who,
what,
who does shit like this?
And December,
this is what all saint nick is coming down the fucking tube.
Right?
Oh,
you better watch out.
You better not cry.
You better not pout up telling you why Santa Claus is coming to town.
Um,
you know,
did I tell you guys,
I went up to a,
I went to this observatory and I was looking at stars the other night cause I'm
not fucking drinking and I'm desperately trying to fill these hours.
When I used to have fun in my life and uh,
I was looking at the moons of Jupiter and,
uh,
one of the moons was named after some fucking,
um,
let's see if I have the information here was named after.
What the fuck would I think?
Like,
you know what,
I can witness,
you guys don't need to know the name.
You don't give a fuck.
One of the moons of Jupiter is named after a,
Jupiter was basically the Roman Zeus,
right when it comes to mythology,
if I remember correctly,
they basically stole all their gods,
like stealing like a fucking script idea,
and they just changed up the names of the characters.
Like,
Nah,
man,
it's different.
We talking about,
so Jupiter was married to a,
I dunno,
I dunno what the fuck her name was Apollonia right,
which is going to use fake names here.
And they had a daughter named die.
Heather are Helena.
I don't know what the fuck her name was.
One of the moons is named after this girl.
And I evidently,
uh,
this is how this,
this is how the story goes and mythology is
Jupiter had basically a crush on his own fucking daughter and his wife,
rather than reporting it to the proper authorities,
was just simply jealous.
Like he was banging some hottie down the street rather than her fucking
daughter.
So Jupiter is banging his own daughter.
His wife gets wind of it,
he gets fucking nervous.
So he turns her into a cow,
not his wife.
He turns his beautiful daughter that he was banging into a Heifer Heifer
evidently is a fucking a fucking cow that doesn't give an a calf yet.
You know,
it's ready to be fucking banged raw dog style,
right?
That's a fucking story.
I swear to God,
if all you,
Jesus freaks out there who are looking down your nose at that sort of myth
mythology,
you'll fucking religion starts to same goddamn way.
Adam and Eve,
first two fucking people,
they were hanging out.
Somehow they became more people.
It's really weird.
Like that guy was basically,
this guy told this fucking story or at least brought it up.
I guess he didn't tell the whole story.
Then I researched it.
It's just the,
uh,
the incest you was the acceptance of incest back in the day.
I don't know if it's creepy or if it just makes sense.
You know,
you gotta be,
you gotta be asking yourself this.
All right.
There's only 40 people on the planet.
All right,
let's just say 25 of them are women.
15 of them are men that doesn't even add up,
does it?
There's 40 Gat does 25 and 15 is 40 see that we all learned something here today
on the podcast.
All right,
let's see.
Let's say 15 a men and 25 are fucking women.
All right?
Now who's kidding?
Who you've been to a bar?
Does 25 fucking women in there?
All right.
How many of them could you completely give a shit?
About 12 good.
Half of them.
You don't give a fuck.
You stone sober.
Yeah,
whatever with you fucking jeans beat it.
All right?
You got weird eyebrows.
Get the fuck away from me.
I don't care.
It's the 12 of them are out the window.
Now you're down to 13 women.
How many of them are going to be hot?
Let's use the bar analogy.
There's going to be about four hot ones.
All right?
Now if there's 25 women and 15 guys and only for those women a fucking hot,
this is a good God damn chance that one of those women is going to be your
daughter.
No laws have been made about it.
You know there's no real Saudi.
You know,
they haven't even invented the fucking wheel yet or the hammer.
There's no does.
No jurisdiction is no jurisdiction.
There's no laws.
I guess that that's why it made sense.
Like why all these religions started that way.
And then Thor banged his sister in front of his daughter and Nope,
nobody questioned the shit.
So anyways,
I dunno what the fuck I'm talking about here.
People.
I'm just trying to get to 50 and it's 51 minutes.
45 seconds bump up,
bump it up to them.
It's time to go watch Monday night football.
Everybody.
All right,
let's hope we have a nice fair game.
I've got a lot of balls saying that as a patriots fan.
Um,
anyways,
I'm looking forward to this.
I don't like it.
I don't have a good fucking feeling.
I just,
I don't like it.
But what's great is,
is I had a feeling that I was going to go undefeated this week,
four no,
with my picks and I went one in three.
So,
uh,
the odds have it that the fact that I think the jets are going to win means my
patriots might win.
Right.
Does that make any fucking sense?
All right.
Listen to this fuck faces.
I'm going to upload this thing and I'm going to put up some pictures that I took
when I was in San Francisco.
How hilarious is that?
You know,
it's like all of a sudden,
I'm not drinking on the road and now,
now I'm taking pictures like God damn tourists,
and I'm telling you how to fry fucking egg.
I don't know if I like it,
but I'm 51 days in.
I'm definitely going to drink again.
Um,
I just need to learn to do it in moderation so my head doesn't get all big and
fat.
All right,
well that's the podcast for this week.
You guys all have a wonderful week.
I hope all your dreams come true when Dacko fuck yourself.
Okay?